[Music]
the allegations are disturbing two women
who do not know each other have each
come forward to the hollywood reporter
with sexual assault allegations which
knoth denies
the alleged assaults happened in 2004
and 2015. the women say they are coming
forward now after being triggered by his
revival of mr big and hbo max's and just
like that oh my carrie
i must have you i was a little hesitant
at first you know because well it's
interesting that it
like this whole thing there's
so much attention garnered on it you
know it becomes a little um
intimidating sometimes for you chris
private life
the first accuser who goes by the
pseudonym zoe was 22 in 2004 she alleges
a then 49 year old noth invited her to
his los angeles apartment once inside he
immediately kissed her then quote pulled
off her shorts and bikini bottom and
began to rape her zoe claims to have
yelled stop when she alleges he didn't
she pleaded with him to use a condom
[Music]
at the time sex in the city had recently
aired their series finale zoe claims she
feared no one would believe her if she
reported the alleged assault what side
are you on
better be mine the second accuser who
goes by lily was 25 in 2015. she claims
the then married 60 year old asked her
on a date in manhattan and after quote
she had too much to drink lily agreed to
go to knoth's apartment
the next thing she knew quote he was
having sex with me in a chair i was kind
of crying as it happened according to an
alleged text reviewed by the hollywood
reporter knoth messaged quote did you
enjoy our night i thought it was a lot
of fun but i wasn't quite sure how you
felt is it intimidating to be called the
perfect man i'm not being called that by
anybody
no one's calling me the perfect man
certainly not my friends or family
in a statement to e.t north calls both
accusations quote categorically false
adding the encounters were consensual
should we take another ride
life's too short not to in the wake of
the allegations peloton has pulled their
viral spot spoofing big's death from
their social pages to new beginnings
[Music]